hey bun it's Mike from order flows and
welcome to this presentation on the
order flows Delta search for NinjaTrader
8 and if you're not familiar what the
Delta surge is it's a free indicator
that we offer on our website it's free
just go to order flows comm and you'll
see you can download it for free off our
website you just got to enter your email
address and the reason why I'm shooting
this video is because you know over the
last several weeks there's been some
changes with some of the programming and
some people were getting issues saying
you know the license wasn't registered
even though it was a free indicator so
you know we went back we looked at and
solved what the problem was for certain
people some people had no problem some
people had problems we were finally able
to rep to isolate the issue and we've
updated the software and again it's on
the website you go there it's free
there's no charge for this indicator now
before I jump into it I just want to go
over a brief disclaimer you know
understand that trading does involve
risks you know nothing is certain in
life except death and taxes so like I
said it's a free indicator all you have
to do is go to order flows coms last
Delta search HP ml and I'll take you to
a page you know we scroll down to the
bottom of the page just enter your email
address and you after that you click
Submit and then takes you to the
download page and it runs on ninjatrader
8 it doesn't run on TOS it doesn't run
on sierra chart it's for ninja trader 8
and yes it will run on the free version
of ninja trader 8 as well and you know
if you're not into order flow if you're
just using a normal bar chart yes it'll
work on a normal bar chart and I'm going
to show you how to put it on a normal
bar chart so what the Delta surge does
is it measures increases in order flow
Delta and you know people hear the term
Delta in regards to trading and order
flow Delta is different than options
Delta don't confuse them right order
flow Delta is a net difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
versus you know Delta in reference to
options is different right Delta
measures the sensitivity of an options
theoretical value to a change in the
price of the underlying asset that's
completely different than order flow
Delta so now you're gonna ask you know
what's well what's the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers well
have to understand there's different
types of market participants right you
have aggressive traders and you have
passive traders aggressive buyers are
the buyers that buy at the market they
lift the offer aggressive sellers sell
at the market they hit the bid passive
buyers are those who work a limit on the
bid or below the bid passive sellers are
sellers who work a limit on the offer or
above the offer so you know most of us
were familiar with dome okay and if
you're looking at the dome right you're
seeing the bids and the offers above and
below the current where the markets
trading those are passive traders people
that are working offers on the up side
people that are working bids on the down
side okay those traders are happy to
wait for the market to come to them
they're trading but they're they're
passive in their activity right now for
a trade to occur
someone has to cross the bid-ask right
someone has to sell to the passive
buyers or someone has to buy from the
passive sellers okay someone has to be
aggressive otherwise price won't move
it'll just stay there just a seventy
seven and a half at seventy seven and
three-quarters so and this is an order
flow trader chart right what in order
flows trader chart does it's a volume
footprint chart and it takes all that
information that you see traded here
going back and forth in the dome and it
puts it into an easy to read format okay
so it's going to you know you can look
at on a minute base chart the thirty
second chart you go five minute chart
you can look at a range based chart
volume base chart many different ways to
look at what you see traded on a dome
right if you're looking at a dome you
know you kind of rely on your memory oh
my gosh what traded here what traded
there you know and it's just happening
so fast on a dome where if you look on a
footprint chart it just you know it puts
it into it easy-to-read format so you
know what traded at what price how much
volume traded here how much volume
traded there etc now Delta on most
volume footprint charts appears at the
bottom okay each bar has a delta okay if
the Delta is positive it means there
were more net aggressive buyers an
aggressive sellers in the bar if Delta
is negative it means
opposite means that there were more
aggressive sellers than aggressive
buyers in a bar and again like I said
you know most software puts it on the
bottom some software will put it you
know right below the bar or above the
bar it just depends on your software you
know some people like myself prefer to
see it on the bottom some people say I
can't be bothered looking down they're
fine you know you can get software that
will put it underneath but you know I
like to keep it there on the bottom
clean up my chart a bit because
otherwise you're looking at just more
numbers up there so Delta to me is one
of the foundations of order flow right
the other two being imbalances and point
of control now what makes Delta so
powerful is its market generating
information that tells you who is
dominating the market right now so what
the Delta surge is going to do alright
it's gonna take all this information
right you see I said every bar has a
delta and it's looking for increasing
Delta either increasing positive or
increasing negative you can see this is
a minis we got a little surge happening
right here you see the Delta going from
positive 184 to 587 to 1400 as the
market makes new highs so what it's
telling you is aggressive buyers people
are coming in in force and buying more
and more and more right it's causing
this market to make new highs so what
the Delta surge does is it analyzes the
order flow Delta looking for increases
either positive or negative over several
bars and signals un aggressive buyers
meaning positive Delta is expanding have
taken control or aggressive sellers
meaning the negative Delta is expanding
you know like going from minus 102 - 200
- 500 have taken control so you know for
example okay here you can see a small
Delta surge happening right before the
market pops up to new highs after we hit
the highs we see a delta surge cell
happening right here as the market
starts selling off so you know it's a
handy little tool but I'm going to show
you how it you know just
like I said you know it will work on a
normal order flow volume footprint chart
okay which is this but you know I
realize not everybody uses volume
footprint chart and then that's fine but
if you want to add order flow to it you
can download the Delta search import it
you just import it as you would any
other indicator and you know you could
adjust the settings there's not many
settings it's basically the increase
right here I just have it set in this
case ten and ten so I'm looking for an
increase at ten percent over the next
three bars so you can see this is the e
minis you know this is just over the
last couple days this is I'm shooting
this video on Saturday April 25th so let
me just put the date up here just so you
can see here date range things you can
see yesterday was a 24th does it mean
he's one minute chart now people say
well you know he gave a signal up here
okay well you know that the earlier
signal was down here again you got to
realize put trading what's happening to
the market in context okay now again
this is a free indicator we kept it kind
of basic and the point being is you know
it's good enough by itself if you put
what's happening in the market into
context okay people say well this isn't
much of a move here but you see how the
snps have been moving lately you know
this is about a five-point move here
here's a few points you know here's a
nice little buy it just doesn't look
like much you know here's some nice
cells this is the evening session look
at this move you know you get short from
up here and get another signal keep you
short here you know from you know
whenever this is 88 down to you know the
70s you know here's a move up a couple
moves up some moves down again this is a
you know it's a 1-minute chart and again
if you were to adjust the settings you
know you'd get probably some different
signals or trust the chart let's go to I
don't know let's go down time frame
because it emini S&P s are a little bit
volatile recently so maybe you want to
look on a shorter time frame say a 30
second chart
we'll say well I know I got to keep up
different charts know you know find the
chart that you trade put the indicator
on there said it's a free indicator you
don't like it you can you can drop it
like I said you know it's a little bit
more volatile now you know what the VIX
I think closed on Friday around 39 so
there's still a bit of volatility in the
market you think well 39 in the VIX is
kind of low especially since we've been
you know above 40 above 50 above 60 for
the last several weeks but you know
waiting for the VIX to get back down to
I'd like to see the VIX get down below
but here's 30-second chart you see
there's a nice buy here here's a nice
little sell okay we stopped you out this
little cell stopped you out but you got
a nice move late in the day here's a
nice little sell here there's some small
trades here you know here's a buy
there's a sell yeah just going back back
back
this was the 23rd I mean look at this
move down this move up you know there's
a move up here this one just sort of
went sideways then you had that big drop
if you remember you know some more buys
down here some sells you know doesn't
work out go sideways and boom get the
nice move but again you know there's a
nice move here move here yeah these are
a bit tricky you got a little bit of a
move just go back again you know here's
a nice buy right before it took off
going back to earlier in the week I mean
there's a nice buy here's a nice buy you
know people say well you know who had a
losing trade here well again you're
buying up near the high of the day do
you necessarily want to be doing that
can the market go higher yes it can
where would you rather buy after you had
a nice sell-off then you get the surge
yeah that's the place that you know in
my mind that you'd rather buy okay so
that's the thirty-second chart let's
expand it a bit let's go to a 5-minute
chart okay again same settings you
all the settings earlier ten and ten all
right I haven't changed them whether
I've gone down to a one minute from one
minute chart to thirty second chart to a
five minute chart and just give it a
second here to pull up the the data but
again you know I'm showing you on these
on different charts because I'm not
saying you have to have all three you
know these different charts open it's
because you know I want you to see that
on different charts on the same settings
I'm looking at the same thing you know
because I realize some people trade a
one-minute chart some people trade a
five-minute chart okay but look at that
right here yeah yeah nice little cell
here but what's better is this nice buy
right here okay it was a buy here here's
a buy here it's a five-minute chart okay
look at this and I sell here and I spy
here okay so when people say well I
don't use a minute based chart I use I
don't know what you want to call it
choose a volume based chart and volume
base is better than tick based in terms
of order flow you know the tick doesn't
tick based chart doesn't take into
account volume but let's just see how
with the exact same settings okay 10 and
10 okay not many signals but there were
some signals here late in the day on
Friday on the Thursday here is a nice
buy here it was a nice sell here I mean
these are just beautiful ones you know
from the 20s down below the figure from
the 90s back up into the teens these not
so good
this one sort of went sideways on you it
goes back here okay so people say well
you know what Mike I don't trade
equities I trade I don't know crude you
know Croods been everyone's focus
recently so it's crude oil crude oil I
got crude here now let's go here at
crude even though with a lot of brokers
they really ramped up the margins with
the volatility but let's just take a
look here let's start with
crude oil one minute chart this is June
crude okay you see it says calculating
so I know it's working right now it just
takes a minute for it first initially to
come up okay there's a little move here
so it'll move down here so they'll move
up you know this one just sort of went
sideways it's a small move up you know
here was just sort of going sideways and
again you know any method of trading if
you're taking a signal basically in the
middle of congestion it's probably not
gonna be very effective you know the
more effective signals are going to be
the ones that occur at clear SiC swing
highs or swing lows like this one here
but anyway let's go back here you know
here's a cell here is the body's didn't
work out here's a nice sell some more
cells buys and they sell there here's
some nice buys just straight up you know
more buys just sell some more buys some
cells here right for the market sells
off now the thing you got to realize
with order flow people always think that
order flow is gonna give them a signal
up here at the high or signal down here
at the low no it's looking for a certain
condition happening in the order flow
that's gonna give you you know the
signal so you know some days depending
on how you have the setting it may
appear it may not appear okay yeah
here's a short there's a buy that failed
goodbye started go up failed then here a
nice buy when your rally from 14 up to
here's another buy it wasn't that big
but this doesn't look very big mess
about 50 cents then of course you had
this nice sell from you know the 1660
1616 dollar area down you know down
below 15 dollars here again some nice
buys and nice cells
um okay well people say yeah I I don't
use a 1-minute chart I mean look at that
look at this cell here in the evening
session 24 bucks down into you know the
23 bucks you know say well I'm more of a
swing trader or I trade a longer time if
I trade a 5-minute chart okay let's take
a look at a 5-minute chart so again you
know I'm not saying you have to have all
these charts open but you know you based
on what you trade I'm just showing you
different examples you know whether it's
a one-minute chart a volume-based chart
a 30-second chart five-minute chart it's
the same settings yeah so yeah you're
not so great on the 5-minute crude chart
yeah there was the sell this buy okay
but again you know it's a free indicator
so you know if it doesn't work for you
it doesn't work for you depending on the
market you trade let's take a look I
don't know euro currency okay he's a lot
of people trade Forex so let's take a
look at the Euro 6 e so one-minute chart
just give it a second it's loading the
ticker replay okay calculating here okay
here was a buy here didn't really do
much it was a buy here you know just
kept you in that market I mean it's a
move from 107 70 up to you know where
you get the sell signal up here at 107
95 then you know the buy signal there
there's a one minute
euro currency chart this first by worked
beautifully the second by no you know
stopped you out okay fine you gotta
learn to take your small losses so you
can be around to catch those big those
big pops there you know there's a couple
buys here this first one nothing
the second one if I would have stopped
you out but you had a nice sell here
okay I mean the
wait 30 area down below the 108 even
area down in here you know pops back up
comes back down this is the euro
currency chart this is the evening
session here this is whatever this is
6:30 Chicago time now people say well
yeah give me this lousy cell signal down
here sakes man the market just sold
off from you know what was this 109 even
down to 108 30 then you get a sell
signal that's might not gonna be a very
effective sell signal okay you know
ideally you'd like a sell signal here
but it didn't happen based on the order
flow
okay just reading what that's happening
in the order flow so again if you take
in this trade you're stopped out okay
fine you know be a big boy about it you
know if you can't take your losses you
get some small winner here or small
winner here you know not every trade is
going to be a winning trade you know
ideally you want to get short at around
the high like here right from 108 90
area down into you know imagine you if I
would have held it hopefully you could
have held it down below the you know the
70 area even if you're just covering it
here we get the opposite signal okay
fine you know say you didn't cover it
down here
or in here on this move back here and
you held it a bit you know by ear you
should be getting out you know a couple
trays didn't work out but those small
trades you take your small loss okay but
you take your small loss so that when
you get the big trade come in you know
you're still you can still participate
you know here's a move up there's a move
didn't really do much just move stopped
you out this one just went sideways
again where would you rather be buying
somewhere near the low or after you just
rallied from the low all the way up to
new highs and you get a buy signal you
know more effective to take buys
somewhere at around the near the low of
the day rather than at or on the high of
the day that's just me I prefer to take
buys near a low swing low low a day then
buys near the high of the day or a swing
high I mean look at that 108 65 all the
way above 109 109 even so
you know what sick another look gold
okay people say why treat
I don't trade any of those things I
trade gold okay fine gold let's keep it
on what is this a one-minute chart I let
you keep about one minute chart I don't
confuse people with so many different
time frames and stuff gold this is
Friday did this move right before the
big sell-off here here I got some little
buys late in the day fine again do you
necessarily want to be taken this high
after you just rally ten bucks in the
gold you know some people will okay fine
but you got to manage your risk and
manage your trade let's take a look here
again similar thing you want to be
necessarily be taking buys up at the
high of the day or sells at the low of
the day at least here it's come after
you hit the low you bounce back up
here's one just sort of grown growing
grinded higher round higher so it's like
coffee and here's a nice cell there's
advi-- again it's it's up near the highs
it did pop up a little bit you know this
sell the annoying thing but again it's
we're on already we're already moving
down you know you're so nice sell here
to sell just went sideways one got a
little bit of a move in here but again
you know you wouldn't be taking these
Long's up here because you should
already be long from you know almost
five six seven eight bucks lower down in
here so you're not gonna be worrying
about getting long up here cuz you
should already be along from you know
down in here down in here you know
here's a nice one
Oh comes backwards to come back to it
comes back to the original area where
the surge was occurring then it
continued on its move back up here
there's a nice buy to a cell moving back
up to another by so again you know it's
it's a free indicator you just go to our
website
where is it here order flow is calm /the
Delta surge dot html' takes you to a
page you got to scroll down to the
bottom of the page you have to enter
your email address hit submit
okay if it doesn't work on your browser
you know people use different forms you
know you know people some people use a
Mac some people use PC some people use
an Android phone
some people use an iPhone you know I've
tested it on several different formats
it'll work sometimes because I can't
enter my email address you just type in
your email address hit Send okay give it
a try again it's free okay I'm not
charging you anything for this but you
know it's the the whole point is to get
you know people understanding on how
they can add order flow to their trading
and for example right if you have you
know a method of trading not involving
order flow and you add a tool like the
Delta surge to it it can help give you
more confirmation to stay in a trade or
get out of a trade or you know or pass a
trade you know I know some people use
order flow to help refine their entries
and exits under their current method of
trading so you know order flow is very
flexible tool but again remember it's a
tool for traders to help them in their
trading okay it's not a system it's it's
not a method per se so you can take a
look at order flow and I think you know
you're gonna find that it really helps
your trading so thanks everyone have a
great day